the Justice Department's investigation into
classified documents held to President Joe
Biden's private home and former office CBS News
has learned about 20 documents in total were
discovered dating back to Mr Biden's years as
vice president attorney general Merrick Garland
has appointed a special counsel to investigate
Mr Biden's handling of those documents and this
morning there's growing concern the discovery
could become a political liability House
Republicans have launched their own investigation
and vowed to hold Mr Biden and members of his
administration's feet to the fire cbs's Christina
ruffini is at the White House with the very late
it's Christina good morning good morning Michelle
well throughout the week West Wing staffers and
various other Democratic officials have expressed
concern to CBS news about how the White House
rolled out this information and why it took them
so long to tell the public President Biden did not
answer questions about the investigation during
meetings Friday with the Japanese prime minister
or as he departed to spend the weekend at his
Wilmington home that home is one of the location's
special prosecutor Robert Herr appointed Thursday
by the justice department will have to look into
as he investigates the president's handling or
mishandling of classified material CBS News has
learned the total number of known classified
documents found is around 20 fewer than 10
were at the Delaware residence in his garage and a
nearby room and by the way my Corvette's in a lock
garage okay so it's not like you're sitting on
the street others including some marked top secret
were located at this Capitol Hill office used by
Mr Biden after his time as vice president what I
can tell you is that we were not given a heads
up I'm here today to announce the appointment
of Robert Herr yesterday the White House said it
was not informed in advance of Attorney General
Merritt Garland's decision to appoint a special
counsel that is something that we learned like
like many of you watching the news but the White
House is also Under Fire for not disclosing the
initial Discovery when it was made in November
right before the critical midterm election our
CBS News colleague Stephen Portnoy were you or
any member of your staff involved in the crafting
of the strategy as to when this disclosure should
be made in advance of CBS News breaking the story
on Monday no Friday House Republicans announced
another investigation into the found documents
telling the Attorney General the American people
deserve transparency and accountability they have
no accounting or inventory of what classified
documents they still possess and why they even
possess them to begin with now many of those
same Democrats draw a distinction between both
the number of Biden documents and the fact
that his team has been cooperating with the
National Archives and former president Trump
and the more than 300 documents that were
either recovered or seized from Mar-A-Lago
Jeff Christina raffini thank you very much